think that Donald Trump is a better
president than Abraham Lincoln there's a
new economist YouGov poll from right
around Thanksgiving and it's a normal
poll where they ask about many things
they ask about presidential approval
opinions of items in the news but then
it has something very interesting and it
asks how do you see Trump versus past
presidents and this is a real insight
into Trump aspyn's and it also relates
to some cognitive biases that are
important to understand so this will be
useful voters were asked which
Republican was a better president Donald
Trump or Abraham Lincoln most
demographic groups no matter how you
slice it were pretty evenly United that
Lincoln was a better president if you
look at men and women men and women
roughly equally mid 70s to mid 20s
believe Lincoln was a better president
okay when you look at different income
groups people earning under 50,000
between fifty and a hundred thousand and
more than a hundred thousand roughly by
the same three-to-one margin they view
Lincoln as the better president than
Donald Trump but when you look at party
identification Republicans by a 53 to 47
margin believe that Donald Trump is a
better president than Abraham Lincoln
now as a side note before we continue
Republicans also think Trump is a way
better president than george w bush by a
71 to 29 margin which is stunning and
again george w bush was no angel truly
but trump but incredible but let's
discuss what's going on here because
there's evidence of a few different
things number one there is a blinding
ideology for some where they truly see
Trump as the best without applying any
real critical thinking to the question
of Lincoln versus Trump they just say
Trump's better for others it's ignorant
they don't really know what Lincoln did
so Trump is better in their minds it's a
combination of ignorance plus lack of
critical thinking for others they
actually don't like Lincoln because he
freed the slaves and it was on the side
of the Union in the Civil War you can
see this when you look at the
regionalized
results we're in the South the numbers
are most skewed against Lincoln and
towards Trump and then there are just
some
sort of general cognitive biases at play
there's the recency bias that's where a
person more easily remembers recent
events compared to something that
occurred a while back that will skew
results this would suggest that any poll
about the current president versus a
president hundreds of years ago would be
skewed towards the current President to
some degree because of recency bias then
you also have the availability bias
which is kind of implicit in what I
already told you this is the human
tendency to think of examples more
easily of things that happened recently
and to imagine that they are
representative in a greater degree than
they are so if you can think of more
things Trump did that you like compared
to Lincoln you extrapolate and you say
well Trump is better on that basis
because I can remember more things that
Donald Trump did so this is about many
things it is in part about the
ideologically blinded ignorant
Republicans it's also about the cult of
personality around Donald Trump but
there are some general cognitive biases
at play as well what I believe this
points to as a strategy and I know I'm a
broken record on this you can't argue
with people who think Trump is better
than Lincoln and rationally explain to
them why they should vote for someone
else let's not even try that as a way to
win in 2020 I told you earlier in the
show when we watched video of that
totally delusional Trump supporter who
said I loved Trump because he's honest
and he has integrity and he has Family
Values you can't argue with that if
someone has a disagreement on tax policy
and they like Trump's tax policy we
might be able to have a conversation
when someone is so deluded and
disconnected from reality the arguments
are a waste of time we're better off
getting out the vote we're better off
finding people who are already on our
side but might not care enough to vote
or might not think their vote is
important those are the folks that we
want to be going after trying to change
the minds of someone who loves Trump's
Family Values or thinks Trump is a
better president than Lincoln it's a
waste of time it's not going to win the
November of 2020 election for us let me
know what you think leave a reply if
you're watching on youtube send me a
tweet at des Pakman we will take
quick break and then talk about
interesting news out of Google and
YouTube I also have some book
recommendations for you an excellent
excellent voicemail glad you're with us
on this first show back after the
Thanksgiving holiday before you go on to
the next video please hit subscribe and
like we are trying to figure out what
this will do for helping us in YouTube's
algorithm I will report back to you but
please before you go onto the next video
please subscribe to our Channel and hit
that like button thank you